RETO MEIER: Today, we're talking
about Google Workspace, Cloud
Functions, and the
Google Maps Platform.
I'm Reto Meier, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud,"
where we serve you
the lowest latency
news from the safety of home.
Introducing Google
Workspace, everything
you need to get anything
done now in one place.
Google Workspace includes
all of our productivity apps,
like Gmail, Calendar, and Drive,
now with three main upgrades.
First, a new, deeply
integrated user experience
that helps teams collaborate
more effectively.
Second, a new
brand identity that
reflects the way our
products works together.
And third, new
ways to get started
with solutions and
price points tailored
to the unique needs of our
broad range of customers.
Cloud Functions
recently leveled up,
now supporting new
run-times, new regions,
and fine grained
security controls.
There's also new support
for local development
with the functions
framework, an upgraded code
editor in the cloud
console, and more ways
to control your costs.
It's a long list of new
features and services.
So be sure to check out the
blog post for a full recap.
2020 has certainly been a
year of unexpected challenges,
and the upcoming
holiday shopping season
will likely see a few more.
With the increased focus on
contactless shopping and order
pickup, it's a
good time to focus
on the omnichannel
shopping experience.
To help, the Google
Maps platform
has two retail solutions, Store
Locator Plus and Checkout,
and this blog covers how you
can leverage these services
to drive conversions.
Season three of
"Seasons of Scale"
kicked off with Carter
Morgan explaining
how to break apps into
independent services
and aim for a stateless
cloud solution.
So be sure to
check out the video
to follow along as
[? Criter ?] Junction choose
which monolithic apps should be
refactored into microservices,
and how stateless
services made that easier.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.